listen up toy story fans the characters
in the disney verse are so familiar to
us
right but how well do you know the
voices behind them
when you watch the four films do you get
that familiar feeling you've heard some
of those voices before
come inside the recording booth with us
as we show you which famous faces
provided their vocal talents for toy
story 4
and all the movies before wow
we're starting with the newbies that
made their debut in the fourth film
the actor who voiced pull string doll
gabby gabby is best known for her role
in an amc series
that ran for seven seasons and won
golden globes
and emmy awards we're talking about mad
men
more recently she's been starring in
good girls she's also well known for her
fiery red hair
have you guessed yet that's right it's
christina hendricks
oh yes i know bo duke kaboom brings a
lot of laughs as the plastic 1970
stuntman with an awesome 1970s handlebar
mustache to match a canadian actor plays
the canadian stuntman
and he also has quite a bit of
experience in action movies packed full
of stunts
we're talking speed the matrix point
break and john wick
this actor also plays a version of
himself in the netflix rom-com
always be my maybe you know who it is
now right
yep it's kiana reeves canada's greatest
stunt man
huh of course where would toy story 4 be
without that all-important character
forky
this spork turned toy drives the plot
but what about the actor behind the
weird googly eyes in unibrow
this isn't his first time voicing an
animated character he also lent his
vocal cords to the disney channel's
amphibia but he's probably better known
for his role in veep
for which he won two emmys he also
played buster bluth on arrested
development it's tony hale
i am not a toy i'm a sport bunny and
ducky are a comedy double act in the
fourth movie so it makes perfect sense
that a comedic duo played the stuffed
blue bunny and yellow duck
these toys that kids can win at the
carnival were voiced by a pair that know
each other so well
they ad-libbed a lot of their scenes the
voice behind bunny is working on a
reboot of the twilight zone but he's
best known for his sketch show with his
buddy
ready for the big reveal it's jordan
peele
[Music]
now you know that info about bunny
you've probably guessed who voices ducky
he's the other half of kian peel's
eponymous comedy series
that's right it's keegan michael key
he's done more voice work as kamari in
the remake of the lion king
he's also been starring in friends from
college on netflix huh yeah how you like
that cheetah huh
we're now on to characters that appeared
in the fourth film but have been in the
franchise a lot longer than that
like bo peep this voice actor has been
nominated for golden globes and emmys
you might know her from her roles in
ghostbusters and pretty in pink
or you might have watched her more
recently on the big bang theory spin-off
young sheldon do you know who it is yet
it's annie potts you would not believe
the things that i have seen
the voice behind the toy cowboy sheriff
needs no introduction
but we're gonna give you one anyway he's
an academy award winner best known for
his roles in major movies from forrest
gump to big
to philadelphia and saving private ryan
not for getting castaway of course
we know that you know who it is so
without further ado woody is voiced by
the one and only tom hanks
that is great if you know the story you
could really help fight
we're in the same boat with the amazing
astronaut this actor is
also a stand-up comedian who tours with
his live show he's been nominated for
many golden globes
and he won for his role in home
improvement you also probably watch him
every holiday season in his film
franchise
the santa claus we are of course talking
about tim
allen both tim and tom have voiced main
characters in
all four films what do you think it is
who the voice inside of you giggle
mcdimples is our final new character
from toy story 4.
the actor behind bo peep's cute little
pal isn't quite as well known as some of
the other stars we've already revealed
but she's still got plenty of credits to
her name
she guest starred on new girl and big
bang theory more recently
she showcased her comedic skills in the
tbs series wrecked
it's ally mackey who's this
cowgirl jessie is voiced by an actor
who's been in the business since 1980.
you might recognize her from adam's
family values and goose point blank
or her more recent tv work in shameless
a series of unfortunate events
on netflix and her voice work as miss
crum in the holiday film clause
ready for the answer it's joan cusack
there are some toys that have been with
woody and buzz from the beginning
and mr potato is one of them he was
voiced by a stand-up comedian that you
might have seen on talk shows and
variety shows
we're talking about don rickles hey look
i'm picasso
although he passed in 2017 before he'd
been able to record for the fourth movie
the team was still able to include him
they went through everything they'd
recorded previously and managed to keep
his legacy alive
where would mr potato head be without
his other half and mrs potato head has
such a standout voice that you'll
probably have recognized it if you've
ever watched the suite life of zack and
cody
she was muriel on that disney channel
show and a style costanza
on seinfeld she also provided the voice
for mama gouda
in the direct video tarzan ii who do we
mean estelle harris of course
someplace dark and dusty
rex is one other toy that's featured in
all four films
his actor has plenty of animation
credits to his name like being bertram
and family guy and gilbert huff in
incredibles 2. he's also acted in plenty
of live-action movies
you might know him as vizzini in the
princess bride or
james hall clueless on tv he played
cyrus and gossip girl
and dr john sturgis in young sheldon
it's wallace
shawn piggy bank ham was in the original
lineup too
and you'll know him well if you're a
pixar fan as he's the only voice actor
to appear in every pixar animation
studios feature film
he was mack in the cars films the
abominable snowman in monsters inc
movies
and the underminer in the incredibles
franchise you know it don't you
it's john ratzenberger defense there's
necklace 380
finest child proof lock in the world jim
varney voiced slinky dog in the first
and second movies
after he passed in 2010 a close friend
of his took on the emotional task of
replacing him for the third and fourth
installments
this stand-up comedian and actor is best
known for playing chet hunter
on boy meets world he was also harry the
hardware store guy on home improvement
alongside the voice behind buzz
lightyear ready for the reveal
it's blake clark and he threw us out
the dress-up rag doll made her debut in
the third movie and came back for the
fourth
and the actor behind her is certainly no
stranger to voice work
she voiced sally carrera in the cars
movies judy hops his mom bonnie in
zootopia
and rosie in a bug's life she was flint
in monsters inc
and mrs graves in monsters university
she also starred in jumanji and cheaper
by the dozen
we're talking about bonnie hunt we're on
a cowboy
we're looking back at toy story 3 now
with barbie's love ken
his actor has racked up the voice work
credits playing jack frost in the 1998
movie of the same name he was chick
hicks in cars and more recently he
played walter in despicable me and
minions
you know it now yep it's michael keaton
i'm not a girl's toy
i'm not we can't mention ken without
moving on to barbie straight after
any disney princess fan is going to know
and love the actor behind the doll's
voice
while you think about which princess she
voices we'll run down some of her other
animated work
there's thumbelina from the 1994 movie
of the same name
aqua girl and marina from batman beyond
and ada from a bug's life
it's time for the big reveal it's ariel
herself jody benson
pretty cool right you have everything
lotso hug and bear also only appeared in
the third film but the voice behind the
old timer bear has appeared in more than
160 movies so chances are you might well
have caught him in something before
like all the president's men his other
animated voice work credit
is as mayor of dirt tortoise john in
rango you got it now
it's ned beatty is i'm a hugger
stretch the purple octopus might have
only appeared in toy story 3 but she
sure made an impression
she has a very distinctive voice so
chances are you already know who we're
talking about but let's list some of her
biggest credits
the color purple ghost and sister act
let's not forget she also voiced shenzi
in the lion king and ursula in
descendants 2.
we know you're shouting at your screen
it's whoopi goldberg
for me for me for me we know it's hard
to choose but we want you to tell us
who's your favorite character from the
entire franchise
while you're here please hit that
subscribe button to be notified when we
release more videos like this
on the things thanks for watching
you